TO ORDER.
WELCOME EVERYONE TO OUR
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION AND.
WE'VE GOT A QUICK ANNOUNCEMENT
AB TWENTY NINE FOURTEEN OR SO
MEMBER COOLEY HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S AGENDA SO PLEASE
MAKE THAT.
NOTATION WE WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. AS SOON AS WE HAVE
ENOUGH MEMBERS PRESENT IN CHARGE
YOU WOULD GO AHEAD AND DIRECT
THE.
MEMBERS TO OUR COMMITTEE.
.
AND SEEING THAT WE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK HERE.
NOT SEEING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK.
MR LOSER THEN DON'T SEE HIM
MISTER FLORA YOU GOT THE LUCKY
NUMBER.
COME ON UP.
OKAY MEMBERS WERE GONNA TAKE UP
BY.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY ELEVEN
SOMETIME BEFORE PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE PREPARED.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YEAH I'M HERE
DAY PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN.
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH MORE FIRE
FIGHTING FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
AB TWENTY ONE ELEVEN WAS THAT
WAS A PILOT PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
SELECT FIRE DEPARTMENTS A GRANT
TO ACQUIRE AND DEVELOP SMART
FIRE FIGHTING EQUIPMENT.
FIND FARMS HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH TECH COMPANIES TO DEVELOP
NEW EQUIPMENT TO EIGHT
FIREFIGHTERS IN SAVING LIVES FOR
EXAMPLE.
NASA'S JET PROPULSION LAB
DEVELOPED ANDRE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE SYSTEM.
DESIGNED DURING NUMEROUS DEVICES
AND SENSORSIN FIRST RESPONDER
COMMUNICATION.
IN THE CASE OF FIREFIGHTERS IT
WOULD INCLUDE GPS HEAT GAS
CHEMICAL SENSORS AND EVEN
SATELLITE IMAGERY OF THEIR
LOCATIONS.
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD GIVE
FIREFIGHTERS EVERY TOOL AT
THERE'S DISPOSAL TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY. AND THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC.
AB TWENTY ELEVEN EXPANDS UPON
THE STATE'S EFFORT TO IMPROVE
THE NINE ONE SIX NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM BY INVESTING IN
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WOULD. MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN FIREFIGHTING
EFFORTS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AS CAPTAIN KIRK MACKENZIE AND
DIVISION CHIEF TROY BLAIR FROM
CONSUMERS FIRE DEPARTMENT.
JOHN.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR
THE CHANCE TO SPEAK ON AB TWENTY
EIGHT ELEVEN.
I'M KURT MACKENZIE OF CONSUMERS
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND I FORWARDED
MORE THAN TWENTY LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY EIGHT
ELEVEN. FROM AS FAR AS THE
NETHERLANDS IN NEW ZEALAND.
WELL WE SERVE JUST TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND. AND KNOW GROVER GAULT
OUR VISION IS FAR REACHING.
FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS.
SERVICE AN AVERAGE OF SEVEN
AMERICANS HAVE DIED BY FIRE IN
AMERICA EVERY DAY.
OVER THE SPAN OF MY CAREER IN
THE U. S. ALONE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND SOULS OF LOS
OUR LIVES BY FIRE MOST PERISHED
IN THEIR OWN HOME.
AND RECENT US FIRE
ADMINISTRATION REPORT.
OUR STATE GOT A SECOND PLACE.
AN AWARD NOT TO CELEBRATE ONLY
TEXAS HAD MORE DEATHS BY FAR
THAN CALIFORNIA.
I RUN MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND
DISPATCHES ON RELATED TO FIRE IN
THIS MOMENT I KNOWLEDGE THOSE
WHO CALLED AND SPOKE TO NINE ONE
ONE DISPATCHER. YET SUCCUMBED TO
THEIR SITUATION.
THE REMAINS OF FREQUENT FAILURE
TO CONNECT THE CAPABILITIES OF
THE AGE WITH THE FIRST
RESPONDERS OR PRIVILEGE SWORN IN
MOTIVATED TO SERVE.
TOO FREQUENTLY WE HEAR VICTIMS
TEXTS
TEXTED A LOVED ONE TO SAY
GOODBYE. I PROPOSE AN
ALTERNATIVE TORE CITIZENS ASKING
AN EMERGENCY DISPATCHER TO TAKE
A MESSAGE IN CASE THEY DIE. I
PROPOSE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS AND
VISITORS SEND TEXT TO NINE ONE
ONE INSTEAD.
I PROPOSE A SOME PHOTOGRAPHS
VIDEO CONTENT THEIR NAME
LOCATION HEART RATE AND NEXT TO
KEN SO FAMILY CAN BE NOTIFIED
WHEN THEY'RE FOUND ALIVE.
I PROPOSE FORWARD THINKING
JURISDICTIONS OF THE STATE JOIN
CONSUMERS FIRES EFFORTS AND
COLLABORATE WITH INNOVATORS AND
CHANGE AGENTS OUR PARTNER
AGENCIES INCLUDE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY NEXT
GENERATION FIRST RESPONDER
PROGRAM.
THE NASA JET PROPULSION LAB ARE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE PROGRAM
AUDREY MOTOROLA SOLUTIONS CHIEF
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERS THE
INTERNATIONAL FORUM FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF FIRST RESPONDER
INNOVATION. AND OF COURSE FIRST
MET.
WE ARE COLLECTIVELY DEVELOPING
THE INTERNET OF LIFE SAVING
THINGS TO LEVERAGE FACIAL
RECOGNITION
THREE D. BUILDING PLANTS
AUGMENTED REALITY AND SMART
CITIES.
ALL THE EFFORT IN TECH FOCUSED
ON TWO THINGS
ENABLING RESPONDERS AND SAVING
LIVES.
I ASKED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
TO LEAD THE WAY SUPPORTING SMART
FIRE FIGHTING FOR ALL THOSE WHO
LIVE WORK AND VISIT THE STATE
POLICE UNANIMOUSLY VOTE AYE ON
AB TWENTY ELEVEN.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MONEY DESTROYED PARA DEPUTY
FIRE CHIEF THE CONSUMERS FIRE
DEPARTMENT. I APPRECIATE YOU
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY A
CONSUMERS FIRE DEPARTMENT IS IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT ELEVEN. AS YOUR WHERE THE
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE OF THE FIRE
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA FACE
UNIQUE INCREASING CHALLENGES.
EVERY DAY AS THEY.
FIGHT FIRE ACROSS THE STATE
DOES SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES
WERE DEMONSTRATED IN OUR RECENT
WILDFIRES THAT THAT OCCURRED IN
SANTA ROSA AND AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S WHILE. THERE ARE
MANY CHALLENGES THAT OCCUR
DURING THESE TIMES.
FROM THE ABILITY TO GET THE
PROPER RESOURCES ON THE ROAD IN
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE
NOTIFICATION OF CITIZENS THERE
WERE IN THE PATH OF THESE
UNFORTUNATE EVENTS. AND ALSO
INCLUDING.
THE ABILITY TO LOCATE
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE BEEN
TRAPPED AND AND.
NEEDING THE ASSISTANCE OF OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE AREAS
AS WELL. SIMILARLY OF
FIREFIGHTERS ACROSS THE STATE
FIGHT STRUCTURE FIRES ON A DAILY
BASIS
WHEN THEY DO SO THEY DO SO WHAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS.
QUITE OLD AND THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THINGS SIMILARLY IN THE
FIRE SERVICE FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
IN THIS EMERGING SMART TAG
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS ASSEMBLY BILL AS.
BEING EXPLOITED TO PROVIDE
THINGS LIKE REAL REAL TIME
TRAFFIC DATA A BUILDING IN ROOM
LAYOUTS FIRST RESPONDER VICTIM
LOCATIONS. OF PHYSICAL
PHYSIOLOGICAL MONITORS AT SUCH
A.
SMART EQUIPMENT WILL SELL
FIREFIGHTERS THE SPACE THEY'RE
ENTERING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS THEY WILL ENCOUNTER
AND THE LOCATION AND STATUS OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE POTENTIALLY
TRAPPED IN THE BUILDING.
INTEGRATING IMPROVE TECHNOLOGY
FOR.
FRANKLY WILL ENHANCE THE
ABILITY OR US TO FIGHT FIRES IN
URBAN AND RURAL SETTINGS AND IT
IS IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE EVERY TOOL AT
THEIR DISPOSAL. TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THEMSELVES AND THE
PUBLIC IS WELL I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
THANK YOU.
FOR THE CHANCE TO SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ELEVEN.
ANY ADDITIONAL LAW SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST OBSERVERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SPORT THINKING.
THANK YOU.
IT'S TIME WILL TAKE ANY.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE.
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS.
I MISTER COOPER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS BILL FORD IT'S IT'S
MUCH. NEEDED OBVIOUSLY
TECHNOLOGY MERGES EVERYDAY AND
EVOLVES AND THIS IS MY HOMETOWN
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU DO IT'S.
NO BIAS. WHATSOEVER BUT NOT ANY
AGENCY AND.
THEY DO A GREAT A DEAL FOR OUR
COMMUNITY
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ALSO WANT TO LIVE IN MY COMMENTS
WITH THE.
PREVIOUS SPEAKER I THINK IT'S A.
GOOD STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO NOW ONLY
VOTING THIS BILL BUT ALSO ASKING
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CONSIDER
PUTTING ME ON AS CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL WAS I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE AND I THINK IF THE. PILOT
PROGRAM DOES WELL WHICH I
BELIEVE IT WILL THAT IT'S ARE
YOU CAN BE A MODEL FOR OTHER
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA WE WANT WE
MUST GET AHEAD OF. OF THIS AND
USE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT IS MADE
AVAILABLE TO US WITH ADVANCEMENT
UP TRYING TO SAVE LIVES AND I
THINK THIS TO STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEED TO.
AND YOU TO WALK ANYTHING FOR
BLOCK.
THIS FOR ALL OUR.
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE BY
THINGS COULD BILL AND. SERVICE
SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE GOT A CHORUS
OF FOLKS WHO ARE WATER CO AUTHOR
OF THE BILL. ABOUT MANY YEARS
AGO I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE DATA FIRE TRAINING.
TOUR AT TEN ACADEMY DOWN NO
GROSSMAN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
ALWAYS REMEMBERED FROM THAT
TOUR.
WAS GOING INTO A BUILDING THAT
WERE THE POWERS BEEN CUT. OUT
FILLED WITH SMOKE AND IT
OCCURRING TO ME THAT YOU CAN'T
SEE.
YOU ALWAYS THINK OF A FIRE OR
SOMETHING AND WALK INTO ITS
BRIGHT YOU CAN SEE YOUR WAY
AROUND AND THEN I GOT TO DO THAT
SAME ACTIVITY WITH SOME
EQUIPMENT THAT ALLOWED ME TO SEE
CLEARLY.
INSIDE THE FIRE AND.
SO IT'S IT'S NOT A IT CERTAINLY
LEFT ME WITH THE IMPRESSION
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING THE
RIGHT EQUIPMENT. TO THOSE THAT
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE. TO
MAKE SURE IT'S SAFE TO USE THAT
PRECEDE YOU BRING IN THE BILL
I'D SAY RIGHT TO BE HAD AS WELL
SO PERHAPS YOU CAN OPEN UP FOR
SERIES OF COAUTHORS COMING OUT
OF HERE. GEO.
MISTER BIGELOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OUR COMMENT AS WELL. WE HAVE
ANOTHER CO AUTHOR PERFECT.
OKAY HAVING ANIMUS CO AUTHORS BY
THE MEMBERS PRESENT.
AND.
WITH THAT AND WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND.
OKAY WE HAVE.
I'LL HOLD ON WE HAVE NOT
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM WE GOT WE
GOT AHEAD OF OURSELVES.
HIS ARMS IF YOU DARE DO A
REMINDER CALL TO SOME OF THE
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE STARTS AT
ONE THIRTY. AND.
WILL GET SOME OF THEM UP HERE
MISTER FLOOR SAYS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL TAKE THE BILL UP.
ABOUT THANK YOU FOR BRING IT
FORWARD TODAY I APPRECIATE AND
EXPECT RESPECTFULLY AUSTRIA I
DON'T THINK SO MUCH.
OKAY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO MISTER QUIRK.
THIS IS ITEM.
THIRTEEN ON YOUR AGENDA AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE APPROACH AND.
BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION NOW
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE FOR
THE ANALYSIS.
JUDY ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WILL READ MY SPEAKING
POINTS.
WELCOME MISTER BERMAN.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK WOULD LIKE
TO THINK COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH HIS OFFICE IN AN EFFORT TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW ADVISORY COMMITTEES
TO MEET VIA TELECONFERENCE
PROVIDED THEY MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS.
THESE INCLUDE ADOPTING
GUIDELINES POSTING ONE PHYSICAL
LOCATION WHERE A QUORUM WILL BE
THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE.
ADVISORY COMMITTEES ARE MOSTLY
OPERATED BY UNPAID VOLUNTEERS
FROM ALL OVER THE STATE.
THEY PROVIDE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
ON A VARIETY OF SUBJECTS THEIR
UNPAID AND HAVE NO DECISION
MAKING AUTHORITY. THAT PROVIDE
THE STATE A GREAT SERVICE BY
VOLUNTEERING THEIR TIME AND
SHARING TALENT THAT WOULD BE
HARD TO FIND ELSEWHERE. ANY
REPORTS THEY PRODUCE ARE
FORWARDED TO THE RESPECTIVE
STATE BODY THAT WILL DEBATE AND
TAKE ANY VOTES NECESSARY.
WITH US TODAY IS SEVEN BORN SEEN
A PROFESSOR AT UC BERKELEY. AND
MEMBER OF THE PETROLEUM MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO JOIN YOU TODAY.
I SERVED ON THE.
PETROLEUM MARKET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION I'M CURRENTLY
ON THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S ADVISORY
COUNCIL PRIOR TO THAT I WAS ON
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
MISSIONS MARKET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
THESE ARE ALL COMMITTEES MADE
UP OF.
COMMISSIONERS WERE VOLUNTEERS.
AND IN THE CASE OF THE WHO
RECEIVE NO COMPENSATION OR
REIMBURSEMENT.
IN THE CASE OF THE P. MAC OF THE
PETROLEUM MARKET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WE HAD FIVE MEMBERS
FREE IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
SAN FRANCISCO PALO ALTO IN
BERKELEY.
SO WE HAD TO COME TOGETHER IN
ORDER TO MAKE ANY PROGRESS ON IN
OUR WORK.
WE BELIEVE VERY MUCH IN PUBLIC
ACCESS OBSERVATION AND
PARTICIPATION. BUT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BAGLEY KEENE
ACT.
GREATLY HAMPERED THE OPERATION
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU TWO QUICK
EXAMPLES WHY ARE MEMBER IN LOS
ANGELES HIS FLIGHT WAS CANCELED
ONE MORNING. WHEN HE WAS COMING
UP FROM LA. AS A RESULT HE WAS
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE HE COULD
HAVE CALLED THE END BUT BAGLEY
KEENE DOES NOT PERMIT THAT.
ON ANOTHER CASE I WAS QUITE
SICK.
I ACTUALLY DID MANAGE TO DRIVE
UP FROM BERKELEY BUT.
HAD I TRIED TO PARTICIPATE WELL
THOSE TOO LATE IT WAS INSIDE THE
NOTICE PERIOD.
AND I WOULD HAVE HAD TO OPEN UP
MY.
BEDROOM WHERE I WAS TO THE
PUBLIC IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE
BY PHONE.
I THINK THERE ARE REASONABLE
ADJUSTMENTS THAT CAN BE MADE IN
BAGLEY KEENE WHILE STILL
GUARANTEEING PUBLIC ACCESS AND
PARTICIPATION. AND AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY EIGHT TAKES A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION I WOULD ACTUALLY
LIKE TO SEE MORE CHANGES THAN
ARE IN THIS BILL BUT I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD START FIRST
START.
AND I HOPE YOU'LL SUPPORT IT.
OKAY DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE I DON'T.
SEEING SOME.
NO ANY.
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM HE WORKED FOR THE%
CALIFORNIA NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MR CORK
FOR CONSIDERING.
OUR CONCERNS THAT WE'VE RAISED.
BUT SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF
THE BILL.
AND.
EXCUSE ME THE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS ON TO MAKE THE BILL.
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
BUT WE WE DON'T SEE ANY REASON
WHY ADVISORY COMMITTEES SHOULD
BE TREATED ANY DIFFERENTLY UNDER
THE LAW.
THAN ANY OTHER BODY THAT IS
SUBJECT TO BAGLEY KEENE.
AND IN FACT OF THE BILL.
HAS
WOULD BE AMENDED BY THIS
COMMITTEE WOULD STILL CREATE.
A SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE.
UNNOTICED IT'S REQUIRED TO BE
PUT UP TEN DAYS PRIOR TO THE
BODY MEETING.
AND THEN ANOTHER NOTICE COMING
OUT WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS I
DON'T FIND LOCATIONS WHERE.
PARTICIPANTS COULD.
CALLING FROM REMOTELY OR
PARTICIPATE VIA INTERNET
REMOTELY.
OUR WE THINK THAT'S CONFUSING TO
THE PUBLIC AND UNDERMINES THE.
HALLMARK PORTION THE BAGLEY
KEENE ACT WHICH PROVIDES A
PUBLIC WITH ADVANCE NOTICE OF
WHAT IT IS THAT THE BODY IS.
DO.
WHEN THE TELECONFERENCE
PROVISION WAS WRITTEN.
DECADES AGO.
IT WAS DONE SO IN ON.
WITH THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING
PARTICIPATING MEMBERS TO.
.
NOT MISS MEETINGS AND FOR THE
BODY TO ACTUALLY DO ITS WORK.
FOR SOME OF THE EXAMPLES THAT
MISTER BORN STEAM.
GAVE EARLIER.
.
I MEAN BIG THE UNLESS THEY
PHYSICALLY MET IN ONE LOCATION
ARE NONE OF THOSE BODIES COULD
ACTUALLY GET ANY WORK DONE SO
THE TELECONFERENCING PROVISION
WAS INTRODUCED AS A CONCEPT.
WELL BUT IN DOING SO ALSO
BALANCED BLUE ABILITY OF THE
PUBLIC TO ACCESS NOT ONLY THE
INFORMATION BUT THE ARM ABILITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE SESSIONS
INCLUDING. PARTICIPATING FROM
THE REMOTE LOCATIONS WHERE THOSE
MEMBERS OF A BADLY CAME BODIES
WERE LOCATED.
WE THINK THAT STILL THE BEST
WAY FOR ON THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE WE'VE WE EMBRACE
SOME OF THE IDEAS THAT MISTER
QUIRK IS RAISED ABOUT A
PROVIDING INTERNET ACCESS.
REQUIRING A QUORUM TO BE.
OUR PRESENT IN A PHYSICAL
LOCATION OF THOSE ARE GREAT
IDEAS BUT I'LL NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF UNDERMINING SOME OF
THE EARLIER. UP PROVISIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN IN THE BILL'S ARM AND
FOR THAT REASON.
WE RESPECTFULLY URGENT NO VOTE.
OKAY ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS ARE FOR QUESTIONS
AND.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
.
I THINK AND I'VE SAID THIS
BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA IS SORELY
BEHIND IN USING MODERN
TECHNOLOGY. I MEAN THE WAY
PEOPLE COMMUNICATE NOW IS.
ONLINE TWITTER I MEAN THERE.
IT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT WORLD AND
I THINK UNDER SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES ITSELF SOMETHING
THAT WOULD HAPPEN AT EVERY
MEETING.
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
AND I WOULD EVEN SAY PHONING
MEMBERS THERE SOMETIMES WHEN THE
WEATHER IS PROHIBITIVE PEOPLE
GETTING THE MEETINGS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE THAT WAY SAW.
I'M IN FAVOR.%
MISTER QUIRK APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENT.
UP THANK YOU.
I WAS PREPARED TO VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL PRIOR TO THE
AMENDMENTS THAT
TAKING THOSE I THINK THEY MAKE.
I'LL SOME STRATEGIC SENSE AND
FOR THE JAVA FROM THE NEWSPAPER
ASSOCIATION I'M A LITTLE BIT
LOST.
.
WHICH.
A YOU MAY BE COMING WITH AND
THAT IS.
IF IS ALREADY A QUORUM PRESENT
AND I'M AT A PHYSICAL LOCATION
WHERE THE PUBLIC WAS ABLE TO
ATTEND.
THIS ROOM FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY ALREADY KNEW THAT'S WHERE
THEY WERE GOING TO GO THEY PLAN
ON GOING TO THAT ANY HOW DOES.
IF IT WE NEED ELEVEN HOW DOES
THE FOR QUORUM HERE HOW DOES THE
TWELFTH THIRTEENTH FOURTEENTH
PERSON WE HAVE A QUORUM WE'RE
HERE MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE ARE
HERE. HOW DOES THE TWELFTH
THIRTEENTH OR FOURTEENTH PERSON
WHO'S AT HOME SICK IN BED
SITTING IN AN AIRPORT LOUNGE
BECAUSE THE PLANE STILL DELAYED
ITS HATCHER HOW DOES THAT?
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE ABILITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET THE
INFORMATION AND AM POCKET OPINED
ON THAT.
WHATEVER'S BUT THE BEFORE THE
BOARD AGAIN THESE ARE ADVISORY
BOARDS ON TOP OF IT THE ONLY
MEMORY VOTING.
ABILITY IN TERMS OF OUT OF
POLICY OR LAW.
.
WHERE WHERE IS THE DAMAGE DONE
TO THE TO THE PUBLIC AT
WELL?
UNDER CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW THE
LOCATIONS WHERE. THE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATE FROM REMOTELY.
BOB HAVE TO BE.
ACCESSIBLE BY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY ALSO WANT TO BE.
WHO MAY ALSO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE?
ARE IN THE MEETING ITSELF.
ARE AND THEY MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO INTERNET TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE
STILL AREAS OF THE STATE THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET.
BOB AND SO THIS WAS DESIGNED
WITH THAT IN MIND.
MOREOVER.
.
EIGHT.
THIS BILL PROBABLY WOULDN'T
ADDRESS THE SITUATION MISTER
BORENSTEIN ARRANGED WHERE THERE
WAS A DIFFICULTY IN.
A MEMBER.
BECAUSE THEY'RE HIS.
PLANE WAS CANCELED HER HIS HIS
FLIGHT WAS CANCELED
BECAUSE IT WOULD STILL REQUIRE
TWENTY FOUR OUR NOTICE.
BUT IN THOSE INSTANCES WHERE
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE YOU
KNOW.
THEY HAVE OTHER JOBS THERE
THEY'RE WORKING ON THEIR
TRAVELING FOR THOSE JOBS.
AND IF A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WANTED TO TAKE PLACE TAKE PART
IN A PROCEEDING ESPECIALLY IN A
BODY THAT COVERS. GENERAL YES
THE ENTIRE STATE.
IT GIVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO.
WITH RESPECT TO THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN ADVISORY BODIES AND
OTHER.
.
TYPES OF.
BOARDS OR COMMISSIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE BAGLEY KEENE ACT.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF POLICY IS
DEVELOPED AT THE ADVISORY LEVEL
AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
PUBLIC TO SEE HERE AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS. AS
THAT POLICY IS BEING DEVELOPED
AND SO THAT'S WHY RIVER REALLY
DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR THE
DISTINCTION.
BETWEEN AN ADVISORY BODY AND AND
OTHER COVERED BY THE AND THAT
THAT'S THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH I.
YOU CAN TAKE A LITTLE EXCEPTION
WITH
S. AREAS THE STATE THAT DON'T
HAVE ANY INTERNET ACCESS THEY
MAY NOT HAVE.
YOU KNOW.
OF FULL T. ONE LINES BUT I
TRAVEL QUITE EXTENSIVELY IN THE
STATE UNLESS YOU'RE ON THE
MOUNTAIN TOP.
I DON'T SEE WHAT WERE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS IN MOST
CASES OBVIOUSLY THERE'S EXTREME
CASES.
ORDERS BREAKDOWNS IN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ETCETERA BUT
BUT AGAIN I'M I'M JUST HAVING
TROUBLE GRAPPLING WITH.
THAT THE MEETING WAS NOTICED TO
BE IN THIS ROOM.
THIS GENTLEMAN'S OUT SICK.
WHY CAN HE NOT PARTICIPATE SO
I'M GOING TO DIRECT AGAIN OUT OF
YOUR TO ANSWER THE QUESTION?
AGOG DRIVE TO BACK TO THE AUTHOR
OF THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR MEETING
NOTICE IS IS SOMETHING THAT HE
BROUGHT UP THAT MIGHT BE A VALID
POINT. IT TWENTY FOUR HOUR
NOTICE IS OUR TWENTY FOUR HOUR
NOTICE STILL PROVISION IN HERE I
MEAN AND IT LOOKED LIKE THERE
WAS.
SO.
THE SAMPLE THAT HE GAVE THE UNIT
IN FAIRNESS TO UP TO THE JOHN
FROM THE NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION. IS A VALID POINT.
BUT ILLNESS AND OTHER THINGS
OBVIOUSLY WEATHER DELAYS IN ME.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS SO I I I
I.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A PERFECT
BILL.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING.
THEY APPRECIATE THE NOT ANY
AFFIRMATIVE.
MISTER QUIRK FOR THE RECORD HE
SAID IF YOU CAN'T AT ME LOOKING
AT MY BLOG INSTEAD OF YOUR.
YOUR HEAD. NODDING.
.
I STILL THINK THAT IT IN IN THE
BIG PICTURE THAT.
IT'S SUPPORTABLE.
.
MAYBE THIS WAY SINCE WE GET
LATER ON I DO APPRECIATE SIR.
WITH ALL RESPECT AYE YOUR YOUR
POINTS OF VIEW I WANT THE PUBLIC
TO BE.
COMPLETELY A MADE AWARE AND I
KNOW MR QUIRK AND I KNOW MR
CRIME BEEN A LOT OF COMMITTEES
AND MEETINGS AND.
MISTER QUIRK AND HE IS PROBABLY
HANNAH AS BIG AS ALEC FOR THE
PUBLIC HAVING INFORMATION AS AS
I'VE FOUND IN THIS BODY. AND ALL
I WOULD AGREE HIS ON HIS GUEST
SPEAKER HERE MISTER BERMAN.
AS WELL BUT.
I I THINK JUST UP THE POINT TO
BE MADE HERE IS YOU KNOW HOW CAN
WE CANNOT. DRAG PEOPLE KICKING
AND SCREAMING. INTO THE TWENTY
FIRST AND TWENTY SECOND CENTURY
OF THERE BUT A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN.
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE NOT BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE MORE BECAUSE THAT
FORMS AND MAX OF THE MEETING IS
GOING TO GO ON WITH THE WITHOUT
THE GUY WITH THE BROKEN DOWN
AIRPLANE OR THE. YOU KNOW THE
ILLNESS THAT MEETING STILL GOING
ON NOW WE ADD ANOTHER VOICE.
A PUBLIC REPRESENTATIVE SOMEONE
WHO'S IN A DIFFERENT AREA OF THE
CUT OF THE STATE THAT NOW WILL
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
SO.
I I APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN AND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
AUTHOR AND HIS SON HIS GUEST
SPEAKER I WAS CALLED A MANNEQUIN
BUT I'D WANT TO BE RUDE TO IT
BUT YOU DID A GREAT JOB TO
BERMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
SIR AND I I WILL BE SUPPORTING
IT.
LITTLE HESITATION BUT BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WHICH BIGELOW.
THANK YOU OUGHT TO THE AUTHOR.
.
LIKE THE DIRECTION THAT YOU
BILLS GOING IN SO I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU MAYBE IT'S A
MORE.
FRAMED AS AS A REQUEST
AS A THOUGHT IN AND AS A
PREDICATE WERE MY POSITIONAL BE
ON THE BILL.
SO UNDERSTAND THAT I'LL SUPPORT
YOUR BILL MOVED AS IT WAS FOR
TODAY. BUT I'M WONDERING WHAT
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT ARE
BEING PRESENTED HERE WOULD BE
WISE FOR US TO.
HAVE LIKE.
A WINDOW THAT WE COULD REVIEW
THIS AND SEE HOW. WE CAN
CATEGORIZE THIS AS A SUCCESS
STORY OF UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY
AND ALLOW ESTABLISH A SENSE OF.
OPPORTUNITY.
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW AND THE
INFORMATION OF THE POSITIVE
ASPECTS OF.
HOW THIS WAS UTILIZED?
AS A TOOL. FOR THE MEETINGS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WOULD SET
IN PLACE IN MOTION.
SOME DIRECTION WHERE WE COULD
ACTUALLY BROADEN THE SCOPE OF.
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD FOR A FOR
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
TO HELP US.
WOULD THAT BE HELPFUL TO YOU
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THAT.
I ATTACK I THINK WHAT'S YOUR
QUIRK IS SAYING IS HE BE HAPPY
TO CHAT WITH YOU WANT TO GET HIS
VOICE BACK. I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT I
WOULD BE WILLING.
YEAH.
YES THEY ARE VISIBLE INTERPRETER
CLAIRVOYANCE.
SO IMPRESSIVE YEAH.
SO ALL EXCEPT THAT IT'S A
WILLINGNESS AND I'LL GET WITH
YOU A ONE OFF I KNOW THIS IS
JUST OFF THE OFF THE CUFF HERE
BUT WE.
IT'S KIND OF COMMITTING.
A LITTLE BIT HERE IT SEEMS LIKE
THAT MIGHT BE. DOABLE SITUATION.
OKAY.
WHICH GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING HIS.
.
THIS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY I THINK
BEFORE US AND SIR NABLUS'S
COMMENTS.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE PUBLIC
WOULD BE DISENFRANCHISED BY WHAT
THEY WERE TO COME TO ME THEY
DON'T COME TO A MEETING.
AND GIVEN THAT GIVEN THE
SITUATION WHERE I'M REMINDED
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL
IN. A NEIGHBORING CITY.
COUNCIL MEMBER WAS CALLED TO
ACTIVE DUTY ACTIVE DUTY IN IRAQ.
AND LAW CAME TO HIS BODY TO SUE
A LOT BECAUSE HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
REMOVED BECAUSE ITS CITY
COUNCIL'S CHARTER SAYS IF YOU
MEET.
MS ON CONSECUTIVE MEETINGS.
AND HE TRIED EVERYTHING AND
ALSO TO THE POINT WHERE.
THE MARINES WERE ALLOWING
DESCRIBED IN TO THE CITY COUNCIL
MEETING SO HE CAN BUILD HIS
RESPONSIBILITIES KNOWLEDGE OF
THIS NATION.
AS AN ARMY LISTED BUT ALSO TO
THE PEOPLE WHO ELECTED HIM.
AND THAT.
YOU KNOW DO THE LAW WAS CHANGED
TO MAKE SOME ACCOMODATIONS AND.
IN A AND IN THAT PARTICULAR WAY
BUT IN THIS PURSUIT DISK TOOK A
SITUATION. GOING TO MY COLLEAGUE
WHO MADE.
GAVE GETS GIVEN EXAMPLE IF A
QUORUM IS MET.
AND INDIVIDUAL A MEMBER WANTS
TO.
NOT CANNOT BE THAT WHATEVER
REASON BUT ALSO BEING ABLE TO.
COME IN USING MODERN TECHNOLOGY
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING THE
RATIONALE WHY SOMEONE WILL
OBJECT TO THAT. THE PERSON IS
APPEALING HIS ROUTE HIS OR HER
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND I UNDERSTAND POLICIES ARE
BEING MADE BUT THE PERSON WHO IS
USING A MODERN TECHNOLOGY WAS
PHYSICALLY CANNOT BE THERE. IS
LISTENING TO THE CONVERSATION IS
IS IS POSSIBLY PROVIDING SOME
GUIDANCE INTO THE CONVERSATION
BUT NOT BEING ALLOWED.
TO VOTE IN THOSE PROCEEDINGS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT THAT IS.
YOUR COMMENTS IS GOING A LITTLE
BIT.
.
ANYWAY I THINK YOU KNOW WHERE
I'M GOING HOUSES OR SOMETHING
ELSE I'M. I THINK I'M I'M A HOLD
ON THE. LECTURE QUESTION WORKERS
WELL WELL I'M.
CLEAN YET COMPLEX ARE MISTER
CHAIR. THE GLOVES.
A PERHAPS MIGHT MIGHT POSITIONS
LITTLE.
MISSTATED.
WE DON'T OPPOSE ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL. ARE FEATURES THAT MR
CORKER'S PROPOSING IN THIS HOTEL
OKAY.
MORE TECHNOLOGY IS MUCH BETTER
WE AGREE WITH ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
WE JUST DON'T LIKE TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN AT THE EXPENSE OF SOME OF
THE PROVISIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IN THE LAW THAT DO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE UNDER
CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW. BY
TELEPHONE BY THE INTERNET
WHATEVER.
WERE SAYING THAT THE NOTICE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT
THE.
LACK OF ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC
TO BE LOCATED AT THE LOCATION
WHERE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
SHOULD NOT BE ELIMINATED.
JUST BECAUSE WE'RE ADDING
TECHNOLOGY TO IT NOW I DOUBT
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE ANYBODY
PARTICIPATING FROM IRAQ.
BUT THEY MIGHT BE IN THE SAME
LOCATION WHERE A MEMBER IS
PARTICIPATING WHEN THEY'RE ON
BUSINESS.
AND THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
AT THAT LOCATION WHICH CURRENT
LAW PROVIDS.
THANK YOU.
NUMBER FOLLOW. YOU KNOW.
STRUCTURE QUESTIONS IN MY MIND
UP.
I DID THAT SEEMS INCONSISTENT
THAT YOU KNOW PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
TECHNOLOGY.
THE PURPOSE OF THE LOCATION WAS
IN FACT THAT THERE WASN'T
TECHNOLOGIES
SOMEONE WOULD NEED TO GO TO THAT
LOOK.
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S NO LONGER THE
CASE AND THEREFORE APPROPRIATE.
FOR SOME REFORM.
AND.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
WELL AGAIN TO TO.
ARM ALLOW FULL PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THERE MAY BE SOME
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE THAT
TECHNOLOGY THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO. A COMPUTER OR
SMARTPHONE OR A VERY BAD HAS
ACCESS TO. THE LOCATION.
BECAUSE THE THE BODY WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PUT OUT NOTICE TEN
DAYS PRIOR TO ITS MEETING
IDENTIFYING EACH OF LOCATIONS
WHERE. PEOPLE WILL BE
PARTICIPATING FROM REMOTELY
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNOLOGY THEY
DON'T NEED TO GO TO EACH OF THE
LOCATIONS THEY NEED TO GO TO THE
ONE LOCATION THAT IS CENTRAL TO
THE MEETING.
WE SHOULD UNDERSTAND IS REFORM
IN THE BILL SHOOT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THAT YES
ARM BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STATEWIDE BODIES AND SO IT MAY
NOT BE EASY FOR. SOMEONE WHO
LIVES IN IMPERIAL COUNTY TO
ATTEND A MEETING WHERE THE
PHYSICAL LOCATION IS IN
SACRAMENTO I MEAN HAVING SAID
THAT YOU WOULD DEBT LIMIT THIS
TO ADVISORY BODIES OF.
AND OF COURSE WHEN I ASKED FOR.
ADDITIONALLY A QUORUM AND.
I THINK WE'VE MADE SOME GOOD
AMENDMENTS TOWARDS THAT END I
WOULD AGREE WITH NOT SURE I
AGREE WITH.
THE CONTINUED A POSITION OF
OPPOSE A ON THIS BILL.
.
I ALSO ASK YOU KNOW WE HAD A
BILL LAST YEAR. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX VERY SIMILAR THAT
THE NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WAS NOT OPPOSITION
TO DID ALMOST EXACTLY THE SAME
THING DO YOU HAVE ANY ERA CAN
YOU WE WORKED OUT A. YELL THAT
WOULD THAT DON'T WITH
AGRICULTURAL BODIES WHERE THOSE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ONE MEETING.
IN VERY REMOTE LOCATIONS ON
FARMS AND THE LIKE AND FOR A
VERY SPECIFIC NEED. WE
NEGOTIATED WITH.
THE AVOCADO COMMISSION AND THE
OTHERS THAT BROUGHT THAT FORWARD
ON THAT VERY NARROW EXEMPTION.
SO COMPROMISE PERHAPS IN SUCH
EXACTLY WHAT RARE EXCEPTIONS
YOU'RE BY.
RIGHT BUT THIS WILL BE MUCH
BROADER THAT WAS JUST VERY
STATED SPECIFIC NARROW NEED ON
ON THIS WOULD BE MUCH BROADER
WOULD OR I DON'T HAVE A POST THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE.
THAT WERE TAKEN HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY.
LIMITED.
WHERE THE BILL WAS THE SCOPE TO
THE AMENDED VERSION COMING OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE YOU'D AGREE
WITH THAT?
SOME EXTENT YES.
.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERSHIP.
SEEING A QUORUM PRESENT WE'RE
GOING TO PAUSE AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GRANT HERE.
BIGELOW.
AND WE ARE CURRY. BERMAN HERE.
INTO.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
DALY.
GALLAGHER.
GIPSON HERE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LIVING.
LOW.
RUBIO HERE SOLACE WALDRON.
OKAY WE'VE ESTABLISHED QUORUM.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS.
.
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
BY THE GUEST SPEAKER OR ROBUST
QUIRK. AS SOMEONE OVER QUIRK
APPRECIATES THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SACREDNESS CALDERON.
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
I BERMAN AYE BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA. JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LEVINE.
LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WALDRON.
WELL THEN I.
THAT BILLS OUT.
IT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY AYE. GRAY AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY. BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LEVINE.
LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WALDRON.
OKAY THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ON
CALL WHEN YOU'VE WON MORE.
AT THIS TIME I'M GONNA PASS THE
AYE GAVEL TO THE VICE CHAIR
MISTER BIGELOW. AND WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM.
NINE ON THE AGENDA.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE WHICH
USER IF YOU PLEASE APPROACH
PRESENT YOUR BILL
.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN TO SAY MY NAME.
MISTER IN IS THERE AND YOU HAVE
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE.
YES I DO PRESENT I DID HEAR A
MOTION.
AND I BELIEVE MY PARTICIPANT I
THINK I MISTER GIBSON MADE THE
MOTION
RUBIO GAVE THE SACK AND.
WELL I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ENTHUSIASM THE IDEA WHAT WHAT
I'D LIKE ASIAN YES BECAUSE.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS JUST SAY
AT LEAST I'M A JOINT HERE BY MR
EVAN RELEASE ON BEHALF OF THE
SEISMIC RESILIENCE INITIATIVE?
AND ATTORNEY LESS LOW BAR.
AND.
I'LL JUST KEEP IT BRIEF AND SAY
THAT.
A GIVEN ALL THE SEISMIC
ACTIVITY WE'VE BEEN SEEING
AROUND THE WORLD WE JUST NEEDED
TO TAKE PROACTIVE STEPS.
AND UP BOTH LOOKING FORWARD AND
LOOKING BACKWARD AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE.
WE HAVE BUILDINGS THAT WILL NOT
BE VULNERABLE AND BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN ANY GREAT LEVEL OF
SEISMIC ACTIVITY TAKING PLACE.
SO ESPECIALLY ALONG THE COAST
THE LINES IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
HAVE A LOT OF FOCUS
SO WITH THAT.
MISTER REISS.
I THINK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SWITCHED AYE HELLO MY
NAME IS EVAN RACE AND I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE U. S.
RESILIENCY CAO.
I AM PLEASED TO JOIN YOU HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE.
IS NOT LOST ON ME THAT TODAY IS
A HUNDRED TWELFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE MOST DEVASTATING EARTHQUAKE
TO STRIKE OUR STATE. IT IS
THEREFORE APPROPRIATE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE I CONSIDERING A BILL
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY LEAD TO
SAFER CITIES.
PROTECTING OUR RESIDENTS AND
ECONOMY.
AS THE CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT THE
U. S. R. C.'S MISSION IS TO
EDUCATE ADVOCATE AND PROMOTE
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF BUILDING
PERFORMANCE IN EARTHQUAKES.
EVERY BUILDING OWNER IN
CALIFORNIA KNOWS THAT WE LIVE IN
EARTHQUAKE COUNTRY AND MOST ARE
AWARE OF THE DEVASTATION THAT
CAN OCCUR IN ADVANCE LIKE THOSE
IN LOS ANGELES NAPA EUREKA. AND
OF COURSE SAN FRANCISCO ON THIS
DATE IN NINETEEN OH SIX.
THE U. S. RC BELIEVES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE BUILDINGS
THEY OWN BY CELL LIVE OR WORK
IN.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE BUILDS
ON SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED AND IMPLEMENTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CSU SYSTEMS
AND SEVERAL CITIES IN THE LOS
ANGELES BASIN AND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA.
THE BILL'S REQUIREMENTS ARE
MODEST IN COST TO THE STATE BUT
MEANINGFUL IN IMPACT
SIMILAR PROGRAMS IN LOS ANGELES
AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE LED
BUILDING OWNERS TO BE PROACTIVE
IN MITIGATING AND RETROFITTING
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS.
IMPROVING THE RESILIENCE OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES INCREASING
THEIR PROPERTIES VALUE AND
DECREASING THEIR RISKS.
I MIGHT JUST ADD THAT ON MY WAY
UP FROM THE PENINSULA TODAY I
STOPPED OFF ON A CITY IN THE
EAST BAY.
CLIENT OF MINE THAT THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC WORKS OF THIS
CITY ASKED ME TO LOOK AT TWO OF
THESE BUILDINGS.
ONE WAS A COMMUNITY CENTER IN
WHICH DOZENS OF CHILDREN RESIDE
EVERYDAY AND WHICH WILL BE
COUNTED ON TO BE A.
SHELTER AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE
THE OTHER WAS THE DISPATCH
CENTER BASICALLY THE NINE ELEVEN
CALL CENTER FOR FIRE AND AND
POLICE A BUILDING THAT'S GOING
TO BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO THE
PERFORMANCE OF THAT CITY AFTER
AN EARTHQUAKE.
TURNS OUT BOTH OF THOSE
BUILDINGS WERE OLDER CONCRETE
BLOCK BUILDINGS WITH WOOD ROOFS
PRECISELY THE TYPE OF BUILDINGS
THAT NEED TO BE IDENTIFIED IN
THIS BILL. TO MADE ALL MORE
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
RESILIENCE OF THE CITY'S IS
GOING TO BE IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL.
MANY OF OUR STATES MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS LIVE IN
BUILDINGS THAT ARE THREATENED
SELVES HIGHLY VULNERABLE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
PARTICULAR CONCERN MORE THAN
FORTY NINE THOUSAND APARTMENT
UNITS WERE RENDERED
UNINHABITABLE FOLLOWING THE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE.
AT A TIME WHEN OUR LEGISLATURE
IS CONSIDERING NEW WAYS TO ADD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK
STATEWIDE. WE BELIEVE IT IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO WORK TOWARD
PROTECTING THE HOUSING WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE ENGINE
OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY YET
MANY ARE ALSO AT RISK AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY ONE WILL PROVIDE
VITAL INFORMATION TO BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
TO USE IN DEVELOPING INCENTIVE
AND PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS TO
RESTORE FUNCTIONALITY.
AND PER SERVE JOBS AFTER ANOTHER
MAJOR SEISMIC EVENT THIS IS THE
VERY DEFINITION OF RESILIENCE.
SO THEREFORE I BELIEVE THAT AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
DEMONSTRATES THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO A SAFER. MORE
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OF
ITS RESIDENTS AND I URGE ITS
ADOPTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
PRESENTED WILL TRY TO KEEP THESE
BRIEF YOU KNOW.
DOWN TO ABOUT A MINUTE HAVE TWO
MINUTES.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE NUMBER OF
PRESENTERS.
SIR HAS GOT TO BE VERY BRIEF
MIGHT MY NAME IS LES LOW BUT I'M
AN ATTORNEY FOR THE LAST FOUR
DECADES SPECIALIZED IN ENERGY.
ENVIRONMENTAL RESILIENCY KINDS
OF THINGS AS WELL AS BUSINESS.
ALSO PRESENT OF A COMPANY CALLED
ET HE CUBA OPTIMIZERS WHICH
DEALS WITH. ENERGY ENVIRONMENTAL
ECONOMIC AND BUSINESS
CONSULTING.
I'VE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
U. S. GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL OF
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OR SO.
AND HAVE RECENTLY BEEN SPENDING
A GREAT DEAL OF TIME WITH THEM
IN TERMS OF RESILIENCY.
DID A SIX MONTH STUDY OF THE
CITY OF BOSTON.
DOING DEVELOPING A CASE STUDY
ON RESILIENCY IN BOSTON WE
LOOKED AT THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
TERMSA HORIZONTAL VERTICAL
INFASTRUCTURE. BUT WE ALSO
LOOKED AT THINGS IN TERMS OF THE
HUMAN ASPECTS
SOCIAL EQUITY ISSUES
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES.
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES POLICE
DEPARTMENT FIRE DEPARTMENT SO
FORTH.
WHAT THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
WE LEARNED IN LOOKING AT
RESILIENCY IS THAT IS THE HUMAN
ELEMENTS IN THE RESILIENCY THE
PEOPLE THAT DETERMINE WHETHER
DOT THE CITY OF BUILDING A
COUNTRY? COUNTY OR WHATEVER OUR
BUSINESS IS GOING TO BE
RESILIENT.
I SECOND THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE. I JUST BEFORE ME AND THAT
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT.
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. LEAST ABLE AND
LEAST LIKELY TO BE A RECOVER
FROM MAJOR DISASTERS
IN THE CASE OF BOSTON THAT WAS
OBVIOUSLY. THINGS SUCH AS
CLIMATE CHANGE WHETHER ISSUES
HURRICANES
AND UNFORTUNATELY TERRORISM. AND
CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY
EARTHQUAKES.
AND IF WE HAD THE MAJOR WE WILL
HAVE THE MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
EVENTUALLY THE KIND OF DISASTER
SOCIAL EIGHT THAT. IS REALLY
TERRIFYING IS NOT JUST THE HUMAN
LOSS OF LIFE THAT WILL CURB WE
DON'T GET AND DO SOMETHING
DRAMATIC SOON.
IT IS ALSO THE ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CATASTROPHE THE
THE QUANTITY OF RUBBLE THAT
WOULD BE RESULT FROM THAT FROM
STATS I'VE SEEN WOULD FILL ALL
THE LANDFILLS CALIFORNIAN
PROBABLY. MAJORITY LANDFILLS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THAT
WOULD BE HORRENDOUS
IN ADDITION YOU HAVE THE
CONTAMINATION THE AIR IN THE
SOIL IN THE WALK THE RESULT FROM
THE KIND OF EARTHQUAKE.
YOU HAVE AN ECONOMIC SPIRAL THAT
WOULD OCCUR BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE DISADVANTAGED WHO LIVE IN
THIS KIND OF HOMES WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO WORK LOT OF THEM. AND
MADE THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE THE
BUSINESSES THAT EMPLOY THOSE
PEOPLE ALSO WILL GO DOWN.
CALIFORNIA IS A SIX LARGER SEEK
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BUT IT WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO WITHSTAND THAT
KIND OF DRAMATIC IMPACT ON THE
ECONOMY. WITHOUT A REPERCUSSION
TO GO TO THE STATE AND PABLO
POSSIBLY THE NATION AS WELL.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT
WE KNOW WE CAN DO TO MITIGATE
THAT KIND OF A WRECK FEET
DAMAGE.
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO HAVE THE
COURAGE AND WILL TO DO THAT TO
PASS THIS LEGISLATION.
I ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU THAT THE
U. S. GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL HAS
ASKED ME TO INFORM YOU THAT IT
VERY VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTS THIS
LEGISLATION. I JUST BECAME AWARE
LAST WEEK A TALK TO THEM AND WE
SENT A LETTER BUT IN FOR TWO WE
COULD GET IT IN TIME. OF FOR THE
SHUT OFF PERIOD BUT IT DOES VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF YOU COULD.
WHAT WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TAKE
NAME AND YOUR POSITION?
FROM HERE SO COULD YOU PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M BOB ROEMER SENIOR
ENGINEER WITH THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE HAD BEEN
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE.
WE WORK WITH THE.
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE AUTHOR
STAFF THEY'VE ADDRESSED EVERYONE
OF OUR.
ISSUES.
WE'VE NOW MOVED TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION AND WORK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
AND HOPE TO BECOME SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS SHORT ORDER THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GRAVITY.
COULD WE HAVE THE FOLKS IN THE
AUDIENCE THOSE IN SUPPORT.
YES THANK YOU MELISSA AND MO
WITH SHY ORDER ENTRY ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
I'M HEIDI JERMAINE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE OUT WE WANT TO SAY
THAT WE APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN FOR TACKLING THE TOPICS
OF SEISMIC SAFETY AN EARTHQUAKE
RISK REDUCTION. ARE WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
HIM ON THIS BILL.
SO THAT I CAN PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTIONS
INFORMATION THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
FOCUS OF FUTURE MITIGATIONWORK
ON BUILDINGS WITH FUNCTIONS THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO COMMUNITY
RECOVERY. AND THEREBY WE THINK
UP THAT WE CAN HELP AND
ASSEMBLYMAN NAZARIAN HERE CAN
HELP CALIFORNIA BE MORE
RESILIENT FUTURE EARTHQUAKES.
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
WELL BETWEEN HER AND THAT THE
HARD WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING WITH US. ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE GONNA MOVE
TO A NEUTRAL POSITION AS SOON AS
THE AND THEN IT'S GOING TO THE
BILL AND WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE IDEA.
OF OF BEING MORE AWARE OF OUR
BUILDINGS ARE.
NOTHING'S WORSE FOR BUSINESS FOR
MY FOLKS AND NOT BEING ABLE TO
SURVIVE AN EARTHQUAKE AND WERE
ALREADY DOING A LOT OF THIS BUT
WE APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR US SO WE CAN DO MORE
THANK YOU. SO FOR CLARITY REAL
QUICK.
THE BILL DOES HAVE AMENDMENTS
ALREADY AND.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE
NOT AWARE OF ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE AMOUNT IS CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL THAT LIMITS CURRENTLY
IN THE BILL MAKES NEUTRAL QUE SO
YOU'RE NEXT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE CLARITY.
I AM A TWEENER ALSO I'M RANKERS
THING WITH THE STRUCTURE AND
YOUR ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
SEVEN MEN WERE GOING TO WORK
WITH HIM MOVING FORWARD WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. WE ALSO NOTE
FUNDING HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED GETS
WE LIKE TO WORK WITH AND MAKE
SURE WHATEVER FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE IS USED IN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY.
NEXT.
BALLINGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE MOVE TO NEUTRAL.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNLESS HE'S AMENDED TO
INCORPORATE THE.
AMENDMENTS THROUGHOUT LIFE IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT.
ONEROUS STANDARDS ARE NOT
IMPOSED ON SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS
AS WELL AS ENSURE THAT.
SELLERS AND BROKERS OF
POTENTIALLY VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
CAN PROVIDE MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION TO BUYERS OF THOSE
BUILDINGS.
REGARDING POTENTIALLY BOND WILL
INCLUDED IN THE.
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNERS
GUIDE EARTHQUAKE SAFETY.
SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
UNTIL THOSE ARE. INCORPORATED IN
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU KNOW
VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ANYONE ELSE TWEETERS.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE I GUESS MISTER DALY.
REGARDING THE REALTORS CONCERNS.
AND THE AMENDMENTS THERE
SEEKING.
.
IS THERE ANY POSSIBILITY OF OF
FINDING A.
THE COMPROMISE THERE OR IS THAT
A NON STARTER FOR YOU KNOW THAT
THANK YOU FOR ASKING I WAS
GONNA.
PLACE IT IN MY CLOTHES OF.
QUITE FRANKLY IT WAS JUST VERY
LAST MINUTE.
SO WE DECIDED TO AT LEAST LET
THE BILL GO FORWARD WILL WORK ON
IT. THERE'S THREE AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR I THINK.
WE'RE.
PRETTY COMFORTABLE WITH AT LEAST
TWO OF THE THREE BUT WE PROBABLY
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
DISCUSSION.
SO I THINK IT'S GONNA PROGRESS
WILL THANK YOU APPRECIATIVE
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT SAID ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS IF NOT.
AND THIS IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED.
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT WEBSITE DO
PASS YOUR YOU HAVE THAT IN THEM
IN THEIR.
DO PASS.
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
YOU PLEASE.
KALRA.
GRAY YES.
BIGELOW.
MITCHELL.
NOT LOADING.
WHO BIGELOW NOW VOTING? ACOSTA.
CROSS THE NOT VOTING. AT WE ARE
CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
LACKEY.
LIVING.
LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SOLIS.
WALDRON.
YOUR BILL IS ON CALL ON WILL
HOLD IT ROLE OPEN AFTER OTHER
MEMBERS WHO YOU CAN SEE OR OUT
ANOTHER COMMITTEES AND WORKING.
ALL YOU NEED SEVEN VOTE SO.
I'M SURE YOU'LL ACCOMPLISH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
EVERYONE THANK YOU.
ESTHER WOULD.
YOU HAVE AB TWO THREE THREE.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
YOU JUST HAD A MOTION AND A
SECOND I BELIEVE MISTER GIBSON
MADE IT AND MISS RUBIO SECONDED
THAT. THAT. YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PERCENT IF YOU
CHOOSE I WILL BE BY WILL I
WOULDN'T LIVE AYE YOU MIGHT HAVE
A SUPPORT SUPPORT.
WAY TURN THIS OVER TO MY WITNESS
HERE I APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
AND.
.
LET IT GO AT THAT.
THANK YOU WITH THE WITNESS LIKE
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW YOU CAME
FROM A DISTANCE THANK YOU IS
HEALTHY THANK YOU SO MUCH ADRIN
SHELTON WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE OUR MISSION IS TO
ADVANCE ON PUBLIC POLICY
INSPIRED LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUES. OF MENTAL HEALTH AND WE
PROBABLY SPONSORED THIS BILL AND
COMMAND DOCTOR WOULD FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT RECOGNIZING THE ACUTE NEED
IN OUR STATE TO PROVIDE SOME
STANDARDS AROUND DISASTER MENTAL
HEALTH RESPONSE. AND BUILDING ON
WHAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THINK YOU.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA MELISSA CHAU YOUR ENTRY
ON BEHALF OF THE MENDOCINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IT'S
PART.
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL TELL WITH PROVIDENCE AND
JUST OF HEALTH IN SUPPORT.
DOUG SHIVERS UP WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF THIRTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
IN SUPPORT.
CHECK KOKANEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
FAVOR HOPE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY PULLEYBLANK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT.
SO MY AND HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
AND SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS HAVE SUPPORT IF NOT.
MOVING TO OPPOSITION ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE GRANT BACK TO THE
BODY MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BILL.
SEEING NONE OF THIS IS A TO PASS
A HEALTH THAT'S A WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE I JUST JOINED IT.
CHAIR WORKS WELL. WITH HIS
MEMBERS YOU MIGHT NOTICE THE
BREVITY AND NOW WE'RE MOVING.
SO.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY. BIGELOW.
SUPPORT BUT YES I BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON LIVE GIPSON AYE GLORIA
AYE GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
KILEY. KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LIVING.
LOW.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS AYE AYE SAWS AYE
WALDRON.
THAT DOES.
IS ARE CALL YOU NEED TO VOTES AS
YOU CAN SEE SOME MEMBERS ARE SO.
OUT ANOTHER COMMITTEES
I THINK WE'LL HEAR A FINE JOB
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PROCESS THAT YOU APPRECIATE
THAT.
DOING MY BEST.
I MISS HER WHEN.
THIS IS AGENDA ITEM ELEVEN.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN.
PLEASE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
REYES I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHICH WOULD.
CODIFIES VERBATIM THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER.
ANOTHER BILL THAT APPROACH THIS
TOPIC IN A SIMILAR FASHION WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR LAST
YEAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
SIR WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONTINUE OF CYBERSECURITY WILL
UNFORTUNATELY BE A CONTINUING
THREAT FACTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
JUST AS MENACING AS FIRES
EARTHQUAKES AND FLOODS.
SO WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
BODY DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THERE IS A
MOTION TO DO PASS.
I TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY BIGELOW.
I BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
JONES SAWYER. KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LIVING.
LOW.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
NEED TO.
SO OFTEN AS IRWIN AS PREVIOUSLY
STATED NUMBER MEMBERS ARE
MISSING AT THIS MOMENT FOR
COMMITTEE. OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES
YOU STILL NEED TO VOTES
I'M SURE WILL DO FINE.
THANK YOU VERY ROLE WILL STAY
OPEN ARI THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISS RUBIO.
AGENDA ITEM FIFTEEN.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
WHICH YOU LIKE TO. PRESENT THANK
YOU YES.
WE HAVE YOUR STUTTERING ON THE
IN THE WASN'T CLEAR.
WHAT WAS IT?
MOVES THE BILL. AND WE HAVE A
SECOND.
SO MISTER COOPER MOVED IN HOW IT
THE SECOND IT.
WITH YOU LIKE TO PRESENT I KNOW
YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO
TRAVELED HERE TODAY YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
BEFORE I BEGIN MY PRESENTATION
ON A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE ACTORS
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE SIX. OF THE
ANALYSIS WHICH STRIKES THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL REQUIRING
LANDSCAPING TO BE CONTINUOUS FOR
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND FEET TO
BE CLASSIFIED AS LANDSCAPE.
FREEWAY I'M A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHT UPDATES THE OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING LANDSCAPE FREEWAY
ACT TO GIVE CITIES FLEXIBILITY
TO OBTAIN. OUTDOOR ADVERTISEMENT
SIGNS WITHOUT INCREASING THE
CURRENT NUMBER OF BILLBOARDS
ALONG THE LANDSCAPE FREEWAYS BY
ALLOWING A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
RELOCATE ILLEGALLY.
PERMITTED DISPLAY FOR ONE LAST
KEEP FREEWAY TO ANOTHER. AYE
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE RONALD
BEALS RETIRED CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
CALTRANS TRANSIT TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND MEGAN LOPER OR.
.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA THE
OUTDOOR ADVERTISING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO?
STARK IS LABOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND AG
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE APPRECIATE
AT THE MOTION AND THE SECOND AND
WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION.
I LOVE THE BREVITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT PRESENTER.
RUN DEALS AVAILABLE THEY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
EVEN BEEN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ITEM CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER
FROM CITY OF ARTESIA I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THE BIL.
AND I WANNA THANK ALL A FEW
WORKING REALLY HARD TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS BEEN A LONG
PROCESS BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL WORK OUT WELL FOR. SMALL
CITY LIKE ARTESIA AND MANY OTHER
CITIES WHICH ARE MUCH NEEDED AND
GRAVITY. SO THANK YOU FOR FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR HELP AND I
HAD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ANY OTHER.
FOLKS WHO WISH TO ADDRESS THE
SUPPORT POSITION.
DOES ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NINE DOES ANYONE WISH TO
OPPOSE.
NO ONE WAS TO SPEAK OPPOSE BRING
IT BACK TO THE BODY IS ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
YES MR ACOSTA.
.
MORE OF A COMMENT BUT BILL I'M
NOT.
NOT HUNDRED PERCENT COMFORTABLE.
BUT I SEE MY FRIENDLIER AND I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THIS YEAR
COMMUNITY.
AND THIS IS.
AND IN MANY WAYS A DISTRICT BILL
SO. I'M GONNA BE SPORTING THE
THE BILL TODAY BUT. I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT WE MIGHT BE
LETTING THE CAT OUT OF THE BAG
ON SOME OF THIS
FOR A FUTURE PERMITTING BUT. I
APPRECIATE.
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN GOT THAT'S
GONE INTO THIS AND SOME OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE NOT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A.
MISS REVEALED I WANT AYE AYE.
AS ACTING CHAIR TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT PARTIES TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND DOING EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE DONE TO. BRING THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
TO RESOLVE THIS ISSUE IT'S BEEN
A UPHILL BATTLE FOR YOU. I'M
VERY PROUD OF YOU WHAT YOU'VE
ACHIEVED SO WOULD THIS IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY BIGELOW. BY BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY. BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY. COOPER.
COOPER I DALY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
RUBIO.
YEAH RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
VERY MUCH THAT BILLS ON CALL.
YOU NEED ONE VOTE ON.
IF I COULD PUT A SHOUT OUT TO A
DIFFERENT OFFICES THAT ARE
LISTENING. WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS AND SHE.
MISTER.
IS MR LIVING HERE NOW OUT I'M
SORRY MARKETS AND MISTER LIVING
I DID SEE WALKING AND.
FOR THE OTHER AUTHORS IS AT YOUR
JURY.
AND MR LOW.
AND.
MISTER COOLEY.
THANKS FOR THE CO.
YEAH MYSTIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LIKE TO RESENT AB
EIGHTEEN NINETY. WHICH WILL
ALLOW WINE GROWER CRAFTER
MANUFACTURE CASPER SISLER OFFER
SHARED SPACE WITH THE
CONSUMPTION OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES IS PERMITTED. WHEN THE
POSSESSOR IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT
TO EACH OTHER SHARE A COMMON
STRUCTURE LAST YEAR'S EIGHTY
NINE NINETY SEVEN DID THAT BUT
ONLY FOR. BEER AND WINE IN THIS.
INCLUDES DISTILLERIES WHICH IS
A GROWING PART OF OUR THRIVING
ECONOMY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
VERY MUCH I THOUGHT I HEARD A
MOTION ON THIS SITE MR ACOSTA
DIE HERE A SECOND MISTER GIBSON
WAS A SECOND. FOR THIS I KNOW
YOU HAVE SOMEONE THAT WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER.
CHAIRMAN RICHARD HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS GUILT AND WERE IN
SUPPORT. OF MR LEVIN'S MEASURE
THINGS GOOD GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SPEAKERS
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE PEOPLE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MIKE SKIPPER WITH
ALCOHOL JUSTICE.
ALSO CONSTITUENT OF THE AUTHORS
AND UNFORTUNATELY ON BEHALF OF
ALL CALL JUSTICE I HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I WE BELIEVE THE SEPARATE
LICENSES.
FOR ON STILL CONSUMPTION
DESERVED TO BE SEPARATED.
THAT'S LIABILITY FOR OVER
SERVING.
IS THE DUTY XIN COPY MONITORED
EFFECTIVELY WHEN SHARING
PATRONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS
IN OPPOSITION.
IF NOT BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. THIS IS DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
GREAT.
BIGELOW FIVE BIGELOW TIE ACOSTA.
AYE ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY. DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY. KILEY AYE LACKEY EARTH
LACKEY AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
LOW.
RUBIO.
SO US.
SOLIS BY ANY.
MISTER LIVING YOU NEED ONE MORE
VOTE.
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR SECOND BILL
THAT'S THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LIKE REPRESENTS A LIKE TO
PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE.
WHICH AUTHORIZED A CRAFT SPIRITS
TO SOAR OFFER INSTRUCTIONAL
TASTING SET OFF SALE RETAIL
STORES THAT POSSESSES AN ON
SALE.
INSTRUCTIONAL TASTING LICENSE
SINCE THE LEGISLATURE PASSED AB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE WE'VE SEEN
ENORMOUS GROWTH THIS BILL WILL
HELP OTHERS PARTY ECONOMY CLASS
FERNANDO.
FIGURES IN SUPPORT YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN RICHARD HARRIS AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ARTISANAL
DISTILLERS.
GUILTY AND WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE TO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
KATE FELT WE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
SIERRA ALONG WITH OUR OTHER
PARTNERS.
WORDS BE SPONSORED THE FIRST
OFF PREMISE TASTY INFILL WHICH
WAS AB SIXTEEN OF FIVE AND
TWENTY TEN.
AT THE TIME THE LISTED
MANUFACTURERS DID NOT INCLUDE.
THESE CRAFT DISTILLERS AND NOW
THAT WE HAVE THAT. AS AN OF THE
WORK AUTHORIZED.
DISTILLER WORDS PLAYBILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE SKIP
OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE YOU BELIEVE GRANTING IT
ANOTHER REGULATORY EXEMPTION FOR
SEGMENT OF THE ALCOHOL AND
ST.
ACTUALLY FURTHER A ROADS FAIR
AND EFFECTIVE VALKO ALCOHOL
REGULATION FOR THE STATE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
FOR IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR.
COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE THE MOTION BY MISTER
GIPSON AND A SECOND BY MISTER
COOPER. THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY. BIGELOW. AYE BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY. BERMAN.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY.
TO DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON OUR GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY ALRIGHT LACKEY
AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE HIGH
LITTLE.
RUBIO.
SOLIS.
SO AS I WALDRON.
I'M SORRY.
PLAN NO DOUBT.
YOU NEED ONE MORE VOTE YOUR
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER LEVY BROAD BASED
THEY'LL FINANCES WE GET.
ENOUGH MEMBERS WILL GET BACK TO
THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST.
WE'RE STILL LOOKING FOR.
AUTHORS IS AYE DIRECTORY.
AND MR LOW.
WE ALSO COULD USE SOME MEMBERS.
TO HELP US SO WE CAN FINALIZE
SOME VOTES DO THE ADD ONS.
WE CAN'T WE. WILL OPEN THE ROOM.
SO WE HAVE TO CALL.
YEAH XIN OPENED LAST WEEK THAT
WE CAN WHILE THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OF HIS GOVERNMENT.
I WILL WAS NEVER EVEN TO.
WE FLOORS NUMBER TEN.
LET'S START FIRST WE WANT TO
KNOW WHAT GOES LIST JUST GOES
DOWN.
SO FOR THE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE
WILL TRY TO CAPTURE THIS.
WE'LL START WITH AGENDA ITEM
ONE.
A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON OUT AT ALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
GRAY. AGUIAR CURRY BERMAN.
YES.
BERMAN.
I YES.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER. LOW.
RUBIO.
WHAT'S YOUR.
WE'LL GO TO A. B. EIGHT.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
IF HE B. EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE.
COLOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
GRAY.
I WE ARE CURRY.
BERMAN. BERMAN AYE. BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER. EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
LOW.
RUBIO.
WATER.
THAT BILL IS OUT AS WELL.
.
WE.
LET'S DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT WILL BE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX THAT'LL BE AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ONE. AND A. B. THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I WE ARE CURRY.
BERMAN I'VE.
BERMAN I.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LOW.
SOLACE.
SALAS AYE.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED.
AGENDA ITEM FIVE EIGHTY TWO
THREE THREE THREE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GRAY.
AGUIAR CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
I'VE.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LOW.
WALDRON.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MR THIS.
WE'LL GO TO AGENDA ITEM NINE AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GRAY.
I WE ARE CURRY.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO.
LEVINE.
LOW.
SILAS.
WALDRON
SO.
THE BILL IS STILL IN CALLING
WORLD HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
IT'S GOOD TO LOOK LIKE.
TAKEN TO WE NEED ONLY.
SITTING.
TAKE A TWENTY.
YEAH MIGHT AS WELL WE HAVE.
WE. FOR FOR THE MEMBERS WE DID
HERE.
EARLIER AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AB
TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN AND THEN
NOW.
WE DO HAVE A NOW HAVE A QUORUM
SO WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR
DIRECTION ON AB TWENTY EIGHT.
ELEVEN THAT WAS MISTER FLORES
BILL. IT DOES HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT.
WE NEED IT WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND MISTER CELIS.
YOU MADE THE MOTION MISTER KILEY
YOU SECOND.
THANK YOU. THIS IS A DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY. BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA AYE ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR
CURRY.
BEMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA. COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA.
GIPSON ARE.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LOW. LOW AYE RUBIO.
SO THIS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
WE NEED ONE MORE FOR THAT FOR
MEMBERS ON THAT PARTICULAR BILL.
MISTER FLOOR DID.
EXTEND THE OFFER TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. MANY OF THE MEMBERS
DURING HIS PRESENTATION TOOK THE
OFFER AND BECAME COAUTHORS.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR JUST.
COME SEE US HERE TODAY ASKING
WELL WE'LL TAKE CARE OF THAT.
AND.
ITEM ELEVEN. AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN WHICH COLLIE ABSENT
MEMBERS GRAY. AYE WHERE CURRY.
BERMAN.
OKAY.
THERE'S.
I DON'T ELEVEN.
I'VE.
BERMAN I.
BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
WALDRON.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AT WORK
HERE EARLIER MISTER COOLEY
PULLED HIS BILL SO WITH SKIP
OVER TWELVE.
.
WE HAD.
MISTER QUIRK AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY EIGHT.
WE DID HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON THAT IT IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
CALL THE ROLL HANDSOME.
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB WE ARE CURRY. BONTA.
COOLEY.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO LIVING.
LOW.
LOW AYE.
SOLIS.
AND ON OUR.
AGENDA ITEM.
FOR A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
EMBERS GRAY.
I WHERE CURRY MISTER LAWYER ON
THE ENVIRONMENT.
ITEM FIFTY THREE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
ITEM FIFTEEN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
COOLEY.
GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA. JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LOW.
LOW AYE WALDRON.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE'RE NOW BACK TO AGENDA ITEM
EIGHT AB TWENTY FIVE.
WHEN IF I SEVENTY THREE MR LOW.
DESPITE WHAT.
OKAY.
GOING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I AM SO VERY PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY THREE. OF FIRST OFF
I WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR OUR
VICE CHAIR ERIC AND ALL KEY
STAKEHOLDERS IN ENSURING THAT
WE'VE COME TO A POSITION. RIGHT
NOW WHERE THIS RESPECTFULLY AND
OF WITH GREAT HONOR DOES ENJOY
IT AND I AYE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
WITH ALL OF THE WORK. THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THIS REGARD.
WITH ME TODAY IS MELISSA AND
WALKS IN WITH AND HAS A BUSH AND
AGAIN TO ONCE A STATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF A WORKING
COLLABORATIVE WITH THE WITH ALL
KEY STAKEHOLDERS A TO GET TO
THIS POINT.
SURE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ANALYST'S AMALEK SIN WITH
ANHEUSER BUSCH. WE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW BEER
MANUFACTURES TO PROVIDE A STYLE
APPROPRIATE BRANDED GLASSWARE.
TO THE ON PREMISE AT NO COST TO
THEM.
TO ACCOMPANY BEER THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED CONSUMERS ARE PURCHASE
SCENES OVER EXAMPLE IF YOU GO TO
A BAR RESTAURANT ORDER
MARGUERITE OUR
MOSCOW MULE OR CHAMPAGNE. YOU
HAVE AN EXPECTATION FOR WHAT
KIND OF GLASS THAT BEVERAGE IS
GOING TO BE THREE PRESENTED TO
YOU AND AT YOUR TABLE. WE'RE
TRYING TO THE CREEK THAT
EXPECTATION FOR BEER AS WELL SO
IF YOU ORDER PILSNER STOUT
YOU'RE GETTING THE APPROPRIATE
GLASSWARE I TO BE USED WITHOUT
BEVERAGE THIS IS INCREASING THE
IMAGE OF BEER AND QUITE FRANKLY
MAKES THE BEER TASTE BETTER.
SO ON THIS IS A PRACTICE THAT IS
LEGAL IN TWENTY ONE OTHER STATES
WERE HOPING TO ADD CALIFORNIA TO
THAT LIST AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT THINK IT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM.
BOB MISTER CHAIR PRIMARIES ON
BEHALF OF MILITARISM I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR IS STAFF
WORKING WITH ALL THE
SHAREHOLDERS ONLY A BILL IN THE
AMENDMENTS US FOREIGN.
FORWARD MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE WILLING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
I TO ME I'M TOM MCCORMACK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CRAFT BREWERS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY JUST TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAD DISCUSSED YESTERDAY WITH
THE AUTHOR IN WITH THE CHAIR.
ARE IN THE BILL AT THIS TIME IS
THAT CORRECT.
STIR LOW WOULD YOU PLEASE OF
FRAME THE.
AMENDMENTS.
MAKE SURE THAT CLARITY IS THERE.
YEAH SURE SURE MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
THE.
THE MARKUPS AS AS LISTED.
NUMBER ONE WITH AUTHORIZED A
LICENSED
ON SAIL RETAILER PER LOCATION TO
ACCEPT THAT.
AND NO DIRECT OR INDIRECT CHARGE
UP TO TEN CASES OF RETAIL
ADVERTISING GLASSER FROM LICENSE
YEAR MANUFACTURERS EACH CALENDAR
YEAR FOR USE WITHIN THE LICENSE
LOCATION. MATERIAL LICENSE PURE
MANUFACTURER AT.
NO DIRECTOR IN DIRECT CHARGE MAY
GIVE NO MORE THAN FIVE CASES.
OF RETAIL ADVERTISING GLASSWARE
TO LICENSE ON SOME RETAILER
PROVOCATION EACH CALENDAR YEAR
FOR USE WITH IN THE LICENSE
LOCATION.
AND THE TERM CASE MEANS A BOX
CONTAINING UP TO TWENTY FOUR
PIECES OF RETAIL ADVERTISING
GLASSWARE AND THE TERMS CLASS
WERE MEANS.
A SINGLE SERVICE GLASS CONTAINER
OR CUP THAT CAN HOLD NO MORE
THAN TWENTY THREE OUNCES OF.
LIQUID VOLUME BEFORE EACH PIECE
OF RETAIL ADVERTISING GLASSWARE
SHALL BEAR CONSPICUOUS
ADVERTISING REQUIRED OF A SIGN.
AND.
.
I FIVE THINK GIVING OF RETAIL
ADVERTISING CLASS OR SHOULD NOT
BE. CONDITIONEDUPON THE
PURCHASE OF THE BEER
MANUFACTURERS PRODUCT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK VERY MUCH THE AUTHOR THE
BILL THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR. LISTENING TO OUR
CONCERNS AND.
.
UNDERSTANDING OUR CONCERNS THE
CROPPERS ASSOCIATION IS NEUTRAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON BE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT SKIP WITH
ALCOHOL JUSTICE.
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THE ONLY
APPROPRIATE REFORM IN THIS AREA
OF LAW.
CHIU ELIMINATE ALL GIFTS TO
RETAILERS TO MAIN TERM MAINTAIN
A FIRM SEPARATION OF THE THREE
TIERS.
AND TO ELIMINATE ANY POSSIBILITY
OF CORRUPTION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE BODY FOR
QUESTION.
MISTER GIBSON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE.
I WILL LET THE CHAIR NOW THAT
YOU SELF ANOINTED YOURSELF
SERGEANT OF ARMS AND YOU'VE
TAKEN A.
A GOOD HANDLE ON.
SECURING OUR MEMBERS.
.
BRING IT BACK TO SERIOUSNESS FOR
A MOMENT.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. RARE.
I'M I I SORRY JUST A QUICK.
CON IS ORIENTED LIKE SHARES
THAT'S WHAT EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY AS WELL AS
THE BILL'S SPONSORS WITH A VERY
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS IN PARTICULAR
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION. ARE
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY'RE ABLE
GETS NEUTRAL I THINK IS REALLY
REFLECTIVE OF THE EFFORT THAT
WAS MADE HERE IS DEEPLY
APPRECIATED BY THIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS PROUD TO REPRESENT. A
LOT OF THESE INDUSTRIES OF ALSO
OF ALL STRIPES.
BUT THIS I KNOW IS NOT AN
INSIGNIFICANT EFFORT I
APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT WAS
CONTRIBUTED WITH WAS MADE TO
MAKE ITSELF THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER COOPER WHO ONE ECHO
MISTER LAWRENCE COMMENT THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR REACHING OUT TO
EVERYBODY IN IN COMING UP WITH.
A GOOD BILL A QUESTION FOR MISS
EMMA WATSON STATED THAT THE
CONTAINER. MAKES IT TASTE BETTER
SO WHAT TOP INTIMATED TASTE
BETTER.
ALL THIS DISCUSSION TO REALLY
ONLY TAKE PLACE OVER A BEER SAW.
IT IS NOT MY FIRST BILLION
DOLLAR ROSE.
YEAH.
.
GLASS WEARER CAN AND THERE'S A
LOT OF REASONS LIKE LOS WORKING
MAKE BIT OF BEER TASTE BETTER OR
ANY SORT OF LIQUID TASTE BETTER
HAS TO DO WITH.
THE SIZE OF THE HEAD THE
BALANCE THE CO TWO THAT A
POTENTIAL ALL GLASS CAN A
RELEASE TO SIX SIMILAR TO WHINE.
SO WHAT A CABERNET CLASS COULD
YOU FOR CABERNET.
BUT YOU.
DID THE FULLY AND ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERN MR COOPER I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU.
NOT LOST IN THE IN THIS IS A
CLASS ALL JUST.
AND CUT THING WORKS THE LARGER
THE OPENING THE GREATER THE
OXYGEN THE SMALLER THE LESS.
OKAY AT.
OKAY.
MR LA AT YOUR EXPENSE WHERE
HAVING A LAUGH TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M I'M DELIGHTED TO
DO IT LASTS.
COMMITTEES MEETING IN THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING. CONTINUED ON.
WITH US A SERIOUSNESS OF MIGHT
IN THE CLOTHES PLEASE YEAH.
AND A NUMBER OF YOU HAVE
CONVEYED.
WITH ME IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
DAYS.
SOME CONTINUED CONVERSATION AND
THIS ENCAPSULATES OF THESE
GENUINE EFFORT FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS WORKING WITH THE
VICE CHAIR CHAIR COMMITTEE
STAFF.
AND MY OFFICE TO COME TO WHERE
WE ARE TODAY SO WITH RESPECT ASK
DR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FOR THE
RECORD FOR ALL OF THEM I DO WANT
TO COMPLIMENT YOU. ON YOUR
WILLINGNESS AND AND YOUR
AGGRESSIVENESS IN SEEKING OUT A
SOLUTION WITH ALL THE PARTIES
THAT WERE AFFECTED AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING AND
WORKING TO AMEND THIS TO. HAVE A
POSITIVE OUTCOME SO WITH THAT
THE MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
I THOUGHT WE HAD A MOTION OVER
HERE. BY MISTER GIBSON AND
MISTER COOPER SECONDED.
IT'S WHAT I THOUGHT I HEARD.
THEY DID REFLECT THAT. AND.
.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS.
GRAY. BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY. AYE
WHERE CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BONTA. BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER GOOD FOR AYE
DALY. DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON FAR GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HI LOW HI LOW AYE RUBIO.
SOLIS
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
MR LA.
YOU WERE ABLE TO PASS THE GRADE
YOU ARE NOW OUT YOUR BILL GETS
TO MOVE ONTO APPROPRIATE.
OKAY WE'RE DOWN TO OUR LAST JULY
BELIEVE LESS TWO BILLS MISC MISC
GREAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
PRESENT.
IT'S THE LAST TWO BILLS.
ENTERTAIN US DO WELL.
GO QUICKLY.
WE HAVE A THE NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE WE HAD A MOTION BY MISTER
GIBSON I BELIEVE A SECOND BY
MISTER LOW. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
PACIFIC FLEET AUSTRIA I WROTE.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD ANY SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE. AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS BY THE WAY A MOTION TO
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
GRAY.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ALL I ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY.
I WE ARE CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
UBER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER. EDUARDO
GARCIA GIPSON ARE GIPSON AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
KILEY.
KILEY EYES COOPER I'M SORRY
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HIGH LOW. LOW AYE.
RUBIO.
SALAS.
SOLIS AYE WALDRON.
YEAH IT'S LIKE SIX MONTHS.
MISC CREATE YOUR BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS.
IT WAS AN ENORMOUS SUCCESS FOR
YOU.
COULD I MOVE ONTO AGENDA ITEM
SIX AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY WILL REQUIRE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION.
COLLABORATE ON REGULATIONS
GOVERNING THE OPERATIONS OF
PRIVATE FIRE RESOURCES AND
EQUIPMENT.
THEY KILL IS TO THE DIRECTORY
WHERE ALL TOWARD WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONTINUE.
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION.
I KIND OF THINK YOU MIGHT WANT
TO KNOW LITTLE BIT MORE.
THIS WILL IS THAT IT.
BUT.
I ASKED WHERE I VOTE.
NOT PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THIS
BILL IS THE DIRECT RESULT OF
COMMUNICATION I HAD WHICH.
YES AND CAL FIRE FOLLOWING THE
RECENT WILDFIRES THAT AFFECTED
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS.
FIREFIGHTERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE WORKED TO FIGHT THESE
FIRES AND THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT
PRESENCE A PRIVATELY CONTRACTED
FIRE RESOURCES.
THIS PART CONFUSION AND
QUESTIONS REGARDING HOW PRIVATE
RESOURCES INTERACT WITH STATE
AND LOCAL RESOURCES.
REPORTS INDICATED THE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR EQUIPMENT
WERE INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM THAT
OF THE PUBLIC FIREFIGHTING
AGENCIES.
BY DEVELOPING STANDARD
GUIDELINES FOR COMMUNICATION
IDENTIFICATION AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY WILL PUT AN END.
TO PUBLIC CONFUSION ABOUT
WHETHER FIRE RESOURCES ARE
PUBLIC FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
PRIVATELY CONTRACT FOR A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE AND STRENGTHEN
OVERALL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
STANDARDS TO BENEFIT ALL FIRE
RESOURCES.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST DOUG SUPERZOOM WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS HERE IN SUPPORT
TODAY WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. WE THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT.
THERE'S AN ABILITY FOR THE
STATE TO DEVELOP CLEAR
GUIDELINES AND REGULATIONS ARE
COORDINATION WHEN THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES ARE OPERATING ON THIS
ONSITE THE ANALYSIS DOES OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES A GREAT
JOB OF OUTLINING.
PREVIOUS GUIDELINES THAT WERE
DEVELOPED BY FIRE SCOPE WHICH IS
A BODY THAT BRINGS ABOUT VARIOUS
MEMBERS OF THE FIRE SERVICE
TOGETHER TO TALK THROUGH THESE
COORDINATION OF RESPONSE ISSUES.
AND WE THINK THAT THIS MEASURE
OF REFLECTS THOSE GUIDELINES AND
WILL.
FURTHER STRENGTHEN THE BILL SO
WE HAVE A CONSISTENT STANDARD
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
BRING YOU BACK TO THE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. ON
THIS.
SEEING NONE.
IT'S GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
IT'S A DIFFICULT BILL.
THERE'S THERE IS TO BE A
FIREMAN ON THE FIRE LINES IT'S
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES. AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED FROM THE RECENT
SAPPHIRES SOMETIMES WE DON'T
KNOW WHO'S ON THE GROUND. AND WE
CAN PUT PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY ON
YOU KNOW I KNOWINGLY. AND AT THE
SAME TIME WE MAY HAVE PEOPLE
WORKING.
IN AREAS IN UNMARKED VEHICLES
AND NOT KNOWN WHO THEY ARE SO
HAVING THE ABILITY TO TRACK THIS
IS GOING TO BE. CRITICAL AND
ALSO THE COMMUNICATIONS.
I BELIEVE YOU'RE GONNA BE
WORKING ON ADDITIONAL WORK
THAT'S FINE OCCASIONS AREA SO
FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS THAT ARE
HERE. REST ASSURED SHE'S
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THAT AND
AND WE THANK HER FOR DOING THAT
WITH THAT SAID THIS HAS A DO
PASSED TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE
ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR CURRY FIGHT
AGUIAR CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA. EDUARDO.
GALLAGHER AYE.
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON. GIPSON
AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER. KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE LOW
LOW AYE RUBIO. SALAS.
WALDRON.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
SALAS I'M SORRY I WAS LOOKING
FOR YOU.
WITH.
OKAY WITH THAT SAID I KNOW WE
HAVE THE FULL. PRETTY MUCH THE
FULL BREADTH OF OUR MEMBERSHIP
HERE WILL QUICKLY GO THROUGH THE
BILL'S ONE MORE TIME SO WE CAN
CATCH THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
STARTING WITH AGENDA ITEM ONE A.
B. EIGHTEEN NINETY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GRAY. AGUIAR CURRY. I WEAR CURRY
I BONTA. BONTA AYE COOLEY COOLEY
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
LEVINE. LIVING AYE RUBIO.
WALDRON.
THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
ONE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GRAY. AYE WHERE CURRY.
EVER CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
WALDRON.
SO THAT THAT BILL IS OUT OF.
THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO AGENDA ITEM THREE A.
B. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT. GRAY.
BERMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
RUBIO.
WALDRON.
WE WILL GO TO.
THE.
THIS WILL BE FOR THE CONSECUTIVE
OR THAT IS EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX THAT IS AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY ONE. AND AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR CURRY.
AGUIAR CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GUARD EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER FIVE JOHNSON JUST
SAW YOUR I MEAN.
LEVINE AND SILO.
MR LOW.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
LOW AYE.
SO THIS IS ALL THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT.
WE'RE MOVING ONTO AGENDA ITEM
FIVE AB TWO THREE THREE THREE.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE I WERE OCCURRING. Y.
WHERE CURRY AYE BONTA. BONTA AYE
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
.
JONES SAWYER AYE LIVING.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE WALDRON.
MOVING ON TO AGENDA ITEM SIX
THAT'S AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY.
GRAY.
GRAY AYE OF FUHRMAN.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE RUBIO.
WALDRON.
THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING ON TO AGENDA ITEM SEVEN
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ONE
FISCALLY ABSENT NOW IS ON
SOMETHING I'M VERY GOOD. THANK
YOU HAVE EIGHT. IF YOU DIDN'T
FIND. SURREAL.
AB IT AS GOOD AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THREE AGENDA ITEM EIGHT.
CORRECT.
I.
GRAY AYE. BERMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE RUBIO.
WALDRON.
THE BILL IS OUT. IN THE COLD.
WE'RE LIFTING THE CALL ON AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE. PLEASE
CALL THE MEMBERS.
GREAT.
GREAT AYE. AYE WHERE CURRY.
I WHERE CURRY NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY. COOLEY AYE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING EDUARDO
GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER NO.
THAT WAS FOR LIVING. LEVINE AYE
LOW.
LOW AYE. WALDRON.
THAT BILL IS.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
BARELY.
MOVING TO AGENDA ITEM TEN AB
TWENTY EIGHT ELEVEN MISTER
FLORA.
GREAT.
GRAY I.
I WHERE CURRY. AGUIAR CURRY AYE
BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE.
DALY. DALY AYE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I. EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER ARE JONES SAWYER
AYE. LIVING.
LEVINE I. RUBIO.
WALDRON.
THAT BILLS
I HAD THE BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO AGENDA ITEM ELEVEN.
SO THE AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WITH THE BILLS ARE.
OKAY.
GREAT BY.
GRAY I EVER OCCURRING. OTHER
CURRY AYE BONTA.
I AYE BONTA AYE COOLEY AYE AYE
COOLEY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER BUT DON'T SAWYER
AND LOW.
LOW AYE WALDRON.
BEGIN AT THE AUTHORITY OUT
LIVING TO AGENDA ITEM THIRTEEN.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT.
PLEASE CALL.
I WE ARE CURRY.
I DOUBT VERY AYE BONTA.
BONTA I COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER BY JOHN SAWYER I.
AM MISTER LACKEY WAS CHANGING
HIS VOTE FROM NO TO NOT VOTING
ON THIS ON CORRECT.
SO LACKEY NOT VOTING IN THE
STILL LIVING.
LIVING AYE.
FIFTEEN AND GOING TO ITEM
FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS GRAY.
MISTER GRAY MISTER GRAY AYE
UNDERLYING.
GRAY AYE AYE WE ARE OCCURRING.
I WHERE CURRY AYE BONTA.
BONTA I'VE COOLEY.
LEE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE WALDRON.
THAT BILL IS OUT ONLY.
IF WE'VE MISSED ANYONE PLEASE.
COME UP AND SEE S..
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT OPEN.
YEAH.
THEY'RE GONNA HEAD ON IT WILL
GET.
THANKS EVERYONE I'VE REALLY.
YEAH.
WE WILL TAKE YOU.
WE ONLY SURE.
NOTED WE'RE GONNA LET GUYS OUT
ON.
YEAH YOU I DON'T I WOULD YEAH BY
BILLS.
WHEREAS LIKE UP.
NO NO NO NO.
I'M LIKE I DON'T KNOW.
WE.
NO.
I DON'T THINK SO.
WE GOT.
THANK YOU HOWEVER.
SO WITH
IT'S OUR.
SO I HAVE RIGHT